oh dude i'm calling it predictions
come at me boss if i'm right
boss from heavy spoilers warren from
cosby
canadian ladder start blinking
reject nation ah episode eight baby
episode eight yeah one division i'm so
excited to check this out man
hey guys uh before we go into that
today's video is
sponsored by you guys because guess what
as of filming this on the time we're
filming it we hit 800
000 subscribers thank you guys thank you
so much on episode 8 day and everything
i know
and also on the day we had the lowest
performing videos we've had in the
longest time
thanks guys
so if you guys can go ahead and
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our next
reaction is up for one division that'd
be awesome
also if you could hit that like button
i'm taking this a long intro hey um
this is the full length reaction watch
alongs over at patreon his reaction
highlights thank you everyone who joined
our patreon page so far eric over at
nerd chronic thank you so much
for adding these reaction highlights wow
there's a much longer episode than the
other ones
good luck buddy let's do this
[Music]
oh speaking of division i get my new
rockstar shirt
really
oh damn is this going to be like salem
rob zombie it is the salem
whoa it's like a agatha origins
where's your boston accent
mom what the hell is wrong with you come
on help me
it's a both terrible boston accent
that's what she come to us
i bind you
it's that line from the craft i feel
like you're just making it more powerful
oh
ah ah so the purple change at the
beginning was actually in honor of her
okay
[Music]
oh that's not gonna end well for you
yo that's so full all wet [ __ ] happening
right now
it's so damn good
freaking marvel this is crazy
kind of feels like i'm watching like an
adult disney movie
an adult version of like a disney plus
special which movie yeah
ah origins
oh well we're picking up right where we
left off yeah adorable
how do you not know the fundamentals
yeah i think she's about to start
teaching her
i got close with fake piatro fietro if
you will
[Laughter]
necromancy was a non-starter since your
real brother's body is on another
continent
but you're so crippled by your own
self-doubt but where exactly did you get
even peter
where'd you get a friend
i'll have you know that's a cicada not a
fly
i've studied entomology since last time
oh that's beautiful look at the fistal
flying
it's got so many different forms and
tricks man
oh what's your secret sister please
don't
hurt the bird you just invented
i need you to tell me
directly powerful it's been fun playing
pretend
for a while hasn't it wanda oh no
i'm so excited to finally get some
answers
whoa what is about to happen
that's right are the kids for sure real
real now i haven't i honestly don't know
oh should we see aaron taylor johnson
too
um she did grow up on exactly if we want
all the direct answers it's right there
yeah at that moment love lucy yes
oh no oh i thought she was going to do
the whole reenactment herself
now we can begin one damn
you peek my peek isn't here put it
in the special place for extra
safekeeping
don't look looking for the movie the
[Laughter]
[Music]
cell
wow really was her escape
from all the terrors happening outside
that's crazy
that's directly in your head just so
caught up in like oh i identify with
this girl i know how this feels
[Music]
tony so we're watching the exact memory
that was told in age of ultron by the
end of the episode
you realize it was all a bad dream
oh
always in her don't be scared
you already lifted once
in a lot of ways i got this kind of
helping her yeah
in a very sinister way she's facing all
of her traumas
[Music]
this is like the origin story of her
[Music]
[Music]
so it just came to her
it was drawn down yeah wow
this is gonna make all of her previous
appearances so much better
that's like full-on scarlet witch outfit
there
hey ticket shoot
again
so where are we now the avengers
compound
was the first home vision i ever shared
vision face through the wall
[Laughter]
oh that's the lou skywalker cameo
[Applause]
i just want to work with pride
don't presume to know what you're
feeling
but i would like to know should you wish
to tell me should that be of some
comfort to you the only thing that would
bring me comfort
is seeing him again
i i love that they're doing all this
yeah i really do
this is this is great
i'm so tired
she's so damn it's good
like this way of washing over me again
and again
it knocks me down and when i try to
stand up
it just comes from me again
well because it can't all be
sorrow can it i've always been alone
so i've never experienced loss because
i've never had a loved one to lose
but what is grief if not
love oh that is
such a beautiful line
oh i'd i'd fall for him too i i have
fallen hey
god sorry no that's true crime that this
the channel switched to this kind of
show he definitely does
[Laughter]
parents did brother dead
vision dead but you wanted
[Music]
[Applause]
one moment i have to buzz you in i got
it thanks
oh she's badass
[Music]
tony stark could have learned something
from her when it came to his barf
[Laughter]
technology
what is this why are you showing me this
because you asked to see it
way to give a heads up there hayward
yeah my dude like
yeah it does take a rocket scientist
i just want to bury him that's all i
want not everyone has the kind of power
that could bring their soulmate back
online
back to life no i can't do that
the best i can do is let you say goodbye
to him
here he isn't yours
oh god you were such an [ __ ]
it's fine let her see for herself
i can't feel you
[Music]
what was that that was like was that
this that wasn't the same footage that
we saw when she took
it though right or did they just like
cut away
with that footage to make it look like
she did
[Music]
you guys see the real personalities of
everyone
oh she made western look a whole lot
better
they should be
um thinking all here
delivering they all look happier in
wanda's world
they do all of them especially her
son of a [ __ ]
damn
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh she just had a breaking point
[Music]
oh how crazy yeah
anguish breathe life wanda
welcome home wow should we stay in
tonight felt like a schindler's list
quality to it
yeah especially with the red yeah
[Music]
whoa oh no
i know oh wow she's full outfit there
you're supposed to be a myth
of being capable of spontaneous creation
oh
you know what she's getting at
this is chaos magic wanda yeah
it's you scarlet wish
there's even a little bit of a different
uh uh len graphic
this was like the scarlet witch origin
story
way back to the past explaining it all
how we got to this point flat out
chaos i love that you find out that she
she
actually possessed magic from from the
beginning
they didn't say pietro's body
didn't specify whose body that was right
dude
i i couldn't tell she was being serious
when she was like it's my eyes
my eyes and ears like well she said she
couldn't bring back his body
yeah so it must be like uh uh
uh scratchy or something like that she
transfigured him
good marvel good team
all we needed was a little energy
directly from the source
ready sir oh no
no don't
oh no
no no
i don't care if you are mephisto or not
you're the devil
all right guys it's going to be a one
division week
oh yeah i feel it it's going to be a
wonderful
year for a lot of uploads this week
about one division
uh this is my favorite part of our uh
videos uh for the one division episodes
where greg and john spent like 40
minutes making notes
and then combing through that episode
you know we
film for like 40 minutes and then i edit
for like an hour and a half it's longer
than the reaction
and then uh all people will do is tell
me the thing we got wrong
yeah all that other stuff all that
content those observations
they all get pointed out thrown out the
windows
no one's going to uh read that other
people
already said it so they're just gonna
make sure to let us know
well it's a service really so yeah so
i'll just encourage you guys
right away i'll just do it for you
correct us on anything we get wrong oh
no it's fun it's part of the youtube
world
so you guys go through this scene by
scene because i
really did love this episode this is
personally this is my favorite one i've
always been fascinated with
psychology and also you know someone
who's been in therapy for
like a little over 10 years at this
point uh
diving into like core memories and core
wounds and understanding
that in order to grieve and let go of
things you
oftentimes you got to dive into the past
to let that stuff go and i'm a terrible
therapy patient
i never cooperate i lie about everything
that's the way to do therapy people
and if i encourage you to do it that's
how you further your denial
yeah lie don't open up don't engage with
the process
yeah don't really do it but keep paying
that money yeah throw money down a hole
going through this you you have the
salem witch trials right at the very top
that's obviously honoring agatha
harkness's origin tale
and then you add a little bit more of a
personal additional layer to
it with the fact that that was not only
her coven but that was her mom
right there and then she even kills her
own mom
uh because her mom was a yankees fan and
not a red sox fan
can't get over that boston massachusetts
it's okay it's better than the accents
so yeah we will not attempt those
accents again how do you like damn
apples ma
it felt like something completely
different it didn't feel like marvel at
all yeah yeah especially with like the
practical
like whizzened old corpses that are
thrown down yeah
it did remind me not to keep pulling
this but obviously they got sam raimi
coming in for doctor strange it reminded
me of that kind of thing crashed into
like you said kind of like a disney but
darker hocus pocus
kind of thing yeah no i really felt that
way tag of the harness has been around
for
freak i mean that was that was the
origin of her and it's in the 1600s
so she's been around for at least 100
years if my math is correct well you
know she was frozen under the ice in the
air
i'm trying to give you guys things to
correct us on yeah
let's try to
it goes back to the basement where you
got wanda tied up you started getting
some
freaking answers there first off fake
pietro it's established
right she says she does chris
crystalline possession crystalline
yeah something like that i couldn't tell
if she meant like her eyes and ears is
in like all right popped him out and
made a person out of it or if you have
an illusion or if yeah it's like i just
hypnotized somebody and made him over
for a day but either way
well i think she was just it sounded
like she hypnotized someone because she
specified the body they couldn't get
pietro's body because it wasn't a
different continent
he's full of holes and so she had to do
weird
things but but to exploit wanda's grief
you know in order to be like oh you're
you're not really
securing your own perception of things
so i just threw somebody else in here i
mean but they don't make it clear though
you know they don't make it clear i mean
i still took it as she was still
possessing someone though right so it
still could
be either that or she transfigured uh
sir scratchy or something like that you
know
we still don't know his true nature even
though she says that thing about like
you know
meeting us for real and like sir
scratchings this is more time
yeah i mean she does say with the when
she's holding the
money she does say the real us at one
point so first
the way she talks with scratch scratchy
sounds like there's a there's a being
there's a guy not just some pet that she
has you know this guy knows what's going
on
but she does say crystalline possession
i think she she had to have possessed
some guy's body because even when they
are doing the agatha all the long
sequence he can control things but it
sounds like
wanda's the one i mean obviously one is
the one who can
with the chaos magic can create
realities you can create all this but is
agatha capable of
creating the realities it seemed like in
the agatha long flashback i mean you
know you
first you see her working her outfit
with her purple magic and so maybe
that's what was lingering
around fake pietro was like the you know
quick
uh reworking of his visage or whatever
so maybe it's not like his reality is
warped but maybe it's just you know
some kind of deception or whatever
honoring at this part
but bottom line is not real no i mean
he's not the real pietro at very least
oh
man i feel like they need to make that
crystal clear
they gotta clear that up bring evan
peters back to explain this
the fact that they have evan peters in
here
i think they have to make a clear cut to
the audience
what exactly is going on with that and i
think it's a very clear choice to leave
him out of this episode to get us all
going but
why is it ever peter yeah how was this
possible
and you know because it means it's just
stunt casting or something
like he keep calling him fake when he's
in the post credit scene of the last
episode still yeah snooper's gonna
snooze
we didn't return to any of those guys
this week no we didn't there's still
some slight confusion there other than
the fact that we know it's fake and that
she
obviously when the conversations were
happening that sound like agatha
harkness's questions
in this episode then quicksilver was
asking questions that are like oh that
that sounds like agatha harkness's voice
and even has kind of the
fun personality of agatha martinez
like you really see it you really see
that there you see they're like
same sly like ooh you know i'm i'm
having fun
asking you guys questions a little bit
even though they're like pushing your
buttons and making you hurt
yeah because it has as clearly
established in this episode juana
created all this
and then agatha entered into here yeah
she was attracted by just the sheer
force of magical energy
does that magic be on autopilot then we
go into
uh i don't know what this trope is
called you physically walk around your
memories i love it it's usually in
things that deal with grief when you
have to like uncover
traumatic memories and such like that is
always great visual storytelling
i just wish you were able to do it in
real life you know what they got
they got to get that tony stark barf
technology going they got to get it
going in fact that
they're able to successfully do this and
then knowing that
civil war was such an important movie
from wanda maximoff look at me tying it
in
look at me tying it in that's what we
call real uh connective kind of reaching
easter egg for you guys real
nerd because that's two very different
things um
but you get the memory there of that
piece show tells that aaron that's how i
really thought we'd see aaron taylor
johnson i know
it's like you're seeing all these
memories and how important pietro is to
her
and like why is there one you couldn't
give this it's gonna get taylor johnson
back you're seeing the memories uh
that pietro describes her but they're
adding more to it all these memories and
the gaps they fill in they just sprinkle
and sitcoms
yeah you're watching sitcoms is what
they did you know when she was
being experimented on she was watching
sitcoms and she was with her dad and
that whole memory there was
one little detailed picture left out
when she was watching sicko
when she first bonded with vision when
he faced to the wall she was watching
sitcoms
after everything with her life she was
watching sicko
it's the only thing that's been there
through her for thick and thin yeah
no makes sense it was her escapism um
and her support system yeah that's what
we call a
core core traumatic memory right there
uh which usually occurs between the ages
of five to ten
and uh yeah she was ten years old if i'm
not mistaken with the age of that cut
off
at the age of one that guy can
[Laughter]
yeah i think in this story when when
they do tell in an age of ultron they
specify that they're 10 years old the
core of all this like when you start the
first episode with one division you're
going back
that is the start of her biggest trauma
but also
a defining moment of her escapism
especially with that dick van dyke
episode which was
called hold on one second
okay wait a minute they made a mistake
it's episode 20.
it's episode 20 the show little girl
want us at episode 21.
eric voss is going to ream you
you know he's gonna look that up the
actress had the best delivery on that
line
so they had to go with it yes they were
like it's the take it's the but
maybe it's a bigger part i'm not
remembering your memory she's even
changing her past
it's viral marketing she changed imdb
and our reality mephisto oh
oh baby wanda you don't mess that up
they say in that memory and age of
ultron uh when pietro was telling the
story
that bombs there the but they didn't go
off
and it just sounds like it didn't go off
when peter was telling the story
and then to fill in that gap even more
yeah to see that it was
little wanda who was actually
controlling it
who was stopping it probability
manipulation or whatever she called it
that like burgeoning bit of magic
yeah it was really cool she always had
the magic because the way how
the narrative up until this point
sounded with wanda
is that is that mic on
so on 2 30 in the morning as we're
filming this guys
cameras on the red dots up there the way
the narrative has sounded up until this
point
is that while she was captured her and
her brother by
hydra they were experimented on through
the scepter that's how she got her
powers
was uh basically through there they
established no she's always had magic
ability she was born with this
the mind stone was drawn to her and i
love how within the mindset you get that
beautiful comic image of scarlet witch
that was crazy
yes that was crazy that should be the
thumbnail moment right that
should let's spoil it for everybody i
think we should just get all the big
stuff
all the best moments and make a grid of
them
not even put our own face reaction
just biggest scenes in one vision screw
with everybody at the bottom just write
my fiesta
reed richard richardson ghost writer why
not everyone's
back but yeah no to see that that's yeah
to have that piece of context where it's
like oh you had this magic and the
little detail of like it might have
dissipated and it disappeared entirely
had you not had that experience
with the mind stone to bolster and
further unlock it
yeah making it something that much more
special so they're not rectangling her
story yeah yeah they're they're they're
going they're
filling in more and i want it does make
you wonder
like how much of this was the original
plan because there was a fascinating
interview that started circulating the
internet again
from the time when they were fulfilling
age of ultron and elizabeth olsen was
saying yeah my favorite story is house
of heaven but they would never do that
then marvel
but she seems like incredibly sincere it
was her first time promoting a marvel
movie
i think she really believed it that
there were no plans
to do this i would believe that too and
so i
it like the impression i'm getting is
that they were going with that as their
origin
and then here they were able to find
ways without having to they don't undo
any of that
they just add to it and i love that all
i can imagine
is that it's the subconscious mind of
kevin feige laying easter eggs
unknowingly so that later on he could be
like oh
perfect just use all this
it's got to be some kind of meld of
design and happy accent true then of
course you know just being drawn to the
mind stone there's just some
fascinating lines here that you have
with agatha starting a mentor
saying stuff like the only way forward
is back what she's doing
is that's true like you in order to
heal and let this stuff go she's gotta
face her truths
and it sounds like a helpful
psychological thing but really she's
just trying to figure out like what are
you doing you know yeah
it's like how can i help you or use you
this might have a positive effect on you
but
it's mostly just for my own ends yeah
whatever works really
whatever gets me to the answers i need
regardless of your will
and i love that memory that you get uh
in between age of ultron civil war when
she's watching the tv she's it's at the
very specific core
beginnings of her grieving over pietro's
death because that's something that
wasn't really ever brought back up in
the movies was pietro's death
it's easy to forget so having that there
yeah
so having that here and then vision
phasing through the wall
calling back to civil war in civil war
she was like
hey we talked about you doing that biz
so there must be a couple other times
yeah he abused that
i thought that was going to be the
origin of her being like can you not
do that yeah no this time it was
actually kind of charming so what's the
story there
but man that line what is
grief if not love persevering who
wouldn't want to ride that purple d
after some [ __ ] like that
that love is going to persevere like in
the delivery of that one
that was a beautiful what a good line
like that i'm
it was so i don't know i mean this
show's been doing a whole lot of stuff
that's out of the usual for marvel but
that was such a wonderful scene of of
intimacy that i just wasn't expecting
like halfway through i was like damn
this is such a touching tender moment i
wouldn't have ever expected between two
characters like this
and that's an important moment to nail
down because that's the moment where
their attraction
and the love for them seem to really
begin
in the movies it was like okay i guess
they're kind of into each other now
they're supposed to be together so
they're together yeah
yeah and then here that's the moment of
their true
emotional connection and vision learning
a taste of humanity and humor through
wanda
as well they're learning from one
another in that moment
about more complex human emotions and i
thought that was so beautiful and
i thought they nailed that scene down
man the freaking acting on elizabeth
olsen in this episode
across the board in all stages of life
so good yes so good yeah and she had so
many different flavors to play at so
many times
specifically baskin robbins of grief
right here
and then yeah her showing up wanting to
bury him because they have that footage
where hayward plays it being like yeah
she took his body it cuts away and he
clearly manipulated the footage but he
was you pay attention to that scene he's
manipulating
her he wanted her to see if she if she
could
wake his body up he's an opportunist he
probably like didn't necessarily plan on
her to do that but when she did he's
like well
let's see if she can do it you know we
can't i mean yeah because he uses his
words carefully yeah
he says we're he says like we're
dismantling her
but he doesn't say why he you know
clearly they're trying to piece him back
together and build them as a weapon as
established in the last episode as made
very evident by this post-credits scene
my point with that is hayward he's
choosing his words carefully
saying stuff like it's the ethical the
right thing but he never specifies
we're trying to get rid of it you know
like
he lets her believe that at one point he
even says are you sure not everyone has
the power to bring their
loved one back online i mean uh back to
life
and he lets her go up to the body and
he's saying stuff like i want to
let her see for herself yeah but i think
he was trying to see if wanda could
bring him back to life
if he really wanted vision's body to
just be
no oh i can't let g we can't just get
back online
don't let her near the body because he
just said you're probably capable of
bringing him back
yeah you know you know so he was
manipulating her he wanted her he wanted
this
i could definitely see this was my
favorite hayward sequence i think
because i i thought this was the best he
did
in terms of playing that subtle range of
like i don't know i mean maybe he's not
the evil maybe i'm biased against him
and maybe he is
trying to do the maybe right-ish thing
but yeah
it's just those subtle moves and
manipulations like no
no let her get closer maybe we can warp
this to our advantage right
yeah it's it's so twisted i really want
to see where they're going with him
because they could
i feel like that's the new place where
they could be no he wants they want to
they want to use it as a sentient weapon
because in that post-credits scene he
brings vision's body back to life
without the mind stone so while vision
is back
technically like the physical form of
him he's just an ai
weapon now he's like their new ultron
he's like a zombie ultron yeah yeah
so i'm just saying he's a bad dude
he's a bad guy he always want to bring
it back online and then
using like the fact that uh well wanda
when that episode when she
first uh reveals when she walks through
the hex and is like does this belong to
you yeah
i'm using that item bringing it back
here pulling from that magic
to bring it back to life man that's what
i mean
he was he wanted this to play out and he
like when you go back to that first time
when vision was like help them and
crawling through the hex but couldn't
break through
now it makes sense because vision
seems like this version of vision that
we've been watching in this series
was created from whatever
how she was imbued with the mind stone
herself so
that's why he has a mind stone attack
she created him
reality warping all the chaos magic all
that jazz
but the real visions body never left the
compound facility a sword
and now sword has their sentient weapon
which is i thought was a perfect plot
point because a it sets up those
horrifying stakes but also it's such a
great character beat for wanda to watch
her you're like oh she's gonna freak out
but she doesn't she just
walks out and drives home and that whole
thing with the deed
like being the clincher that sets off
the whole you know
universe right right was so touching
after so much heartbreak you know
i mean you're going through the town
you're seeing you know the whole cast of
people we've been seeing this entire
time
and what they're what they're really
like you know they're just all wandering
the streets
no one seems to even live around there
except for them like everything's empty
it's it's just a few weeks after the
blip it's a few weeks after people
coming back
that's true so you know it's not worth
going back to it it's still a really
dark harsh time i mean we didn't really
come through that
part of the footage john we can't get
crap let's see let's
look come through really quick no no
herb looks so intense
i love how westview still looks like a
studio lot scene
like a universal backlight it looks like
it's right around the corner like marty
mcfly
as much as this is the realistic version
now
yeah the most stagey
yeah it still looks like it looks like a
studio a lot but maybe that's the meta
of the show
you guys tell us everything we missed
there um watch canadian lads video
because he watches this in 0.25
i'm gonna watch it even slower i think
canadian line watches it for the first
time
is that the first time he watches it
that's how he prefers
to watch it generally i watched one
division in triple time and i didn't
catch a thing
it's gonna be my series was that
vision's uh
visions idea to get the house yeah i
mean the deed
or they must have done it together but
yeah it's that dude says you know it's
paid to the order of wanda maximoff and
the vision
you know so it's yeah it's official i
thought they were on the run
yeah that vision has those ways i'm sure
he's an all-powerful sentient ai he
could probably just like
plug his fingers into a computer and
change everything so
that they're no longer being hunted i
don't know i mean that's that's just uh
that was i mean the good thing is is
that they save time on construction
absolutely that's the way to get a house
she built the house you should just
start a contracting business i mean
think how much money there is in real
life and she brought industry to west
view
absolutely absolutely yeah
for the children
if i had one criticism about this
show so far i care about billy and tommy
to a certain extent i care about them
uh in this sense of they mean a lot to
wanda
but in ter as terms of like actual
characters
i don't really feel that attached to
them yeah i know what it means when
they're
like i'm worried about how wanda will
react i'm worried about
what this will do to wanda's emotional
state and i care about
wanda significantly yeah but the kids
i'm like
we've kind of just been rushing through
them and sometimes in the most literal
ways
yeah yeah to the point where you got to
stop the show and go please don't
yeah we stay in the stage for a second
from what agatha says though is like
yes this world you've created with
vision
the kids whereas agatha seems to do
deception
like wood fietra wanda it seems like
agatha from talking about chaos magic
wanda did
create the kids and has created a vision
but vision can only exist within this
little hexagon world right yeah maybe
that vision is gonna take on
uh terminator vision or maybe tv
actually maybe that'll be the key is
maybe whatever this aura
is confused with vision's body and then
we'll get vision back
oh dude i'm calling it predictions
come at me boss
all you bastards a john theory
yeah yeah it's on it's on every time i
predict something it's on
all right guys look who do you think
will win between godzilla versus kong
leave your thoughts down below this was
incredible this is my favorite one
personally i hope you guys enjoyed it
too how do you think this will
end keep a lookout for all fun one
division videos we'll be covering this
week thank you to everyone for watching
thanks to eric and nerd chronic check us
out on patreon for the full link leave
all your thoughts down below i feel like
i've said like a gazillion things of
this enchanting
lord of the rings ending scenario yeah
we got a few more to go
woof woof cycles all over the place one
million
subscribers last but not least got a
shout out to people it's a certain
pledge
mount azar sabir who's saying i hope i
got there right
pseudonymous entity i hope i got that
right
hector the sector no a holiday
mark mckenna quick stevens
tyrell johnson john byers
kevin casemiro differently
adam goldstein kelly hales
chase daniel findura jacob gonzalez
levitt o'dell josh barnes shawn
davis oscar zach
right jordan topolsky my school
the jedi bro lauren american horse
can your fair man thomas
that's part one for today check out part
two of all the names that we call out of
tomorrow's easter egg video
thank you guys so much for pledging to
this tier hopefully you've been enjoying
the lens stories we're going to be
posting more on that tier
you guys rock your support means so much
to us you the bums
all you guys they're all bombs big stars
no it's all right